Susan is in Connecticut hi Susan how are
you oh I should be better this is my
call
sure well I just got some my husband is
surveyed before Facebook I'm having
trouble hearing you can you speak more
directly into your phone
Chalmers or everything upset but I just
served me with divorce papers
I'm sure okay now only what he's
offering is um is 401k and I guess
Curtis
well his IRA and part of his 401k no
alimony no medical no anything else but
I change the house in Connecticut we
also have a house in Florida which he
wants to have solely in his name but
then I'm responsible for all you know um
all the everything that goes with the
house and furniture
totally um I if I do take this you know
I was wondering what should I do with
the 401k and the iris how long you been
married 21 years 21 years and you just
got served today no but two weeks ago
okay we were together on tears prior to
that and how much is in his 401k in
irise um I don't know
I'm it what is um yes um IRA is about
well right now today changed well that
is about 88,000 and um she's and the way
it's worded and the paperwork it's 650
3000 and his 401 K so those did you say
fifty three thousand eighty three sixty
three thousand fish I don't we that's
the whole amount is probably a personal
I see okay in the home in Connecticut is
it paid for
yes
what's it worth um I'm not sure but we
have a really bad monkey here and
everybody's going how did the rustling
rustling noise were I'd say 200 okay and
it has no mortgage okay and the home in
Florida what is it worth um right now
and it's going up in value I would say
about a hundred and thirty fourty okay
and is he keeping other things because
it sounds like he's getting less than
half oh he's keeping noe a couple
thousand of okay so he's offering you a
considerable lump sum payout difference
because 140 is what he's getting and
you're getting 88 plus 63 plus 200 so um
293 50 verses 140 so you're getting a
couple hundred thousand dollars more
than he is does that sound right yeah I
think it where it sounds like it won't
be long yeah it's when I was offsetting
and what is his income he makes a little
rehearse all in the year okay do you
have an attorney yes but he said a
couple things me but I met with him
which a couple people didn't think they
were it was very appropriate um I I was
supposed to come back from this year to
show that get the house ready for sale
because we were going to sell this house
and say it's Florida house and then find
another property so I had gone sighs my
business and mom I just lost my biggest
client and two dirtiest was my last day
and that makes me short $2,500 a month
and we explained that and we knew that
that was coming and that's why we were
gonna sell the Connecticut House and I
was preparing my clock my regrets of my
client um that I was leading do you plan
to stay in Connecticut
I guess I don't have a choice at this
moment why why don't you have a choice
well well because well I have a personal
business left and one it's all I have
okay but you were going to run that from
Florida weren't you um you know oh well
I don't know we were um my husband you
know uh try several different things in
his life he's taken our savings um
that's at least three times to you know
start a new ventures and now are you
chewing are you going to change
attorneys I've been advised to but I
have a friend who I'm meeting with
Monday he's doing he's a really good
friend and he's going to get this
attorney for me okay that's a good idea
he wants to see if I'm too emotional or
the attorneys a jerk that's that's fine
yeah and that's not a bad idea but you
need to get advice in Connecticut as to
what the courts what the climate is in
the courtroom regarding alimony because
basically with $100,000 income and 21
year marriage I'm not sure that your
alimony wouldn't end up a lot more than
two hundred thousand my husband claims
that then if I get oh I don't really
care what your husband claims he's not a
legal expert he has nothing to do with
the law all he is is telling you what he
wants you to hear so what you need is
legal advice in the current climate
there in Connecticut as to because
basically the trade-off you're trying to
decide on is two hundred thousand versus
no alimony that's the only trade-off in
this discussion from the business side
of the equation now there's a broken
heart there's a lot of Tears there's a
lot of betrayal there's a lot of other
things but on the math side it's two
hundred thousand more that you're
getting then he's getting versus no
alimony and let's pretend that the
alimony was fifty thousand a year for
five years
that'd be two hundred fifty thousand and
that would be about an even trade but
let's pretend it's fifty thousand a year
for the rest of your life well then you
wouldn't want to have trade that for two
hundred thousand so you need to find out
what the alimony climate is and what the
law says I don't think
we'll be that high by the way but I'm
just making up numbers to point out we
need to compare what you might get were
you to go to court for alimony versus
well and are likely to get by the way
with a long term marriage in almost any
state versus the 200 extra that he's
giving you I like taking the 200 if all
things are close because it gives you a
clean break and you're not sitting
around waiting on him to send you a
check every month the rest of your life
a clean break emotionally is easier to
heal with does that make sense
well so I like taking the deal as long
as alimony isn't substantially more for
substantially longer but yes I was
looking at the smaller things like a
medical insurance I won't get and I
won't get them all happy you're not
going to be probably I mean you may be
able to negotiate that in but again I'm
not sure I want to rely on him for the
next 20 years of your life for your
medical insurance hey I love the idea of
you having what's known as your own life
to start again because he's not giving
you an option and so though I mean you
know you're going to have your own life
the question is how connected are you in
this now there's no children at home I
assume or okay all right so child
support doesn't enter into the equation
no okay so yeah you need some good legal
advice and so have your friend vet the
attorney and then compare that out and
then go that direction I'm so sorry you
had your heart broken it's a sad sad
deal but that's it that's really what
we're talking about is when you add your
three figures together versus 140 on the
house down there it's roughly two
hundred thousand dollars difference and
compare that to what you might get with
alimony I think you probably have a
pretty good offer but I want you to
check it based on the climate of the
court there I think your husband is what
we call in what divorce attorneys call
he's wanting to buy his way out of this
he's basically writing a check to get to
get his new life and something is
motivating him to do that pretty
strongly so he's uh he's you know buying
the divorce and trying to get a clean
break
so something
thanks for the call
you